[Music]
it's time once again for fan Corrections
[Applause]
[Music]
now listen up and this is a segment
we've been doing where viewers try to
find mistakes on our show they watch the
show they find little mistakes and then
they tell us about them so far there
have been many challengers no winners
yeah
all right because we're fair here if
nothing else right oh absolutely
yeah well tonight a fan named Tristan
from Raleigh North Carolina believes
that he found an error on the show
believes he caught us finally and he
sent us this video hey last night
spotted an error on their show during
your joke about drawing the penis on to
mom's face
yeah they were also told if he's
sleeping take out a sharpie and draw a
penis next to his mouth
[Applause]
I'm going to slow frame the DVR playback
and I'm going to trace your motion it
looks nothing like a penis
oh you think he's got me do you
you think he's got me first of all
Tristan how much saran wrap do you own
that's my first question second of all
nothing like a penis I beg to differ
alright mr. O'Brien let me
[Applause]
that's right I've never seen my own
penis
[Music]
until a doctor true--but for me two days
ago hopefully people manage every other
doctors point we just managed to skip
that I just more than just doctor's
appointments have completely avoided
that area
that's how oppressed I hit anyway I
think that's proof that I'm right once
again so the challenge and I as I said
we're if we're nothing we're fair we're
very very very finish shaping but
they're horribly and comically misshapen
anyway folks the challenge still stands
if you think you've spotted an error on
our show report it at team koco.com
slash haha I found an error we will sort
it out right here on the air let's see
if you've got what it takes
you